I'm not gonna walk home with any men
tonight I'm gonna I'm gonna go hang out
with my friends and then I go home to
the cats no men allowed men get me in
trouble I don't me yeah
number 11. Rihanna during a red carpet
interview with the launch of her Rogue
man fragrance that's crazy all these
women benefit off of sexism like they
benefit off of Beauty in a way men don't
men have to be talented a lot of these
women wouldn't be where they are if they
weren't beautiful if they weren't
stunning and they're okay with sexism or
an opportunity I don't even want to say
sexism but like opportunity
when it benefits them but the downside
that comes with it which is as you age
there's less
than they're mad it's like privilege is
invisible to those who have it and a lot
of women don't realize how privileged
they are and what position that they're
in especially like most of these women
are top 10 20 of beauty you know how
lucky you are to be born top 20 of
beauty 2014. Rihanna was asked by a
reporter what she's looking for in a man
to wear her new product the
multi-talented star took issue with the
very question itself responding
confidently that she's not looking for a
man period what are you looking for in a
man now you ain't looking for a man
but she you dated Chris Brown half your
20s Drake
and then now you're with that other
rapper but okay okay I'm not looking for
a man let's start there the question was
phrased bizarrely making it unclear
whether the journalist was asking Riri
about her love life or her business
venture either way the Starlet was
having none of it when she gave this
sassy response because I feel like I
have so much more to do I feel like
I mean icon that's such a big
title it's such a big thing
um to say or to even be sad about myself
so
now the pressure's on I have to live up
to that number 10. Serena Williams do
you think you could ever beat a guy just
once
only guys sports are worth watching she
has the most number of singles doubles
and mixed doubles Grand Slam titles
among active players combined and was
ranked world number one eight times
between 2002 and 2017. it's Serena
Williams again so it's no exaggeration
to call Serena Williams skillful
talented and graceful when she's on the
court but as the only tennis player male
or female to win two of four grand slams
seven times each as well as the only one
male or female to earn 10 grand slam
singles in two different decades it's
also clearly no exaggeration to call her
one of the greatest athletes of all time
period so when a reporter asked her what
it's like to be quote one of the
greatest female athletes of all time she
quickly and admirably told the
journalist what's what I would really
like to thank Sports Illustrated for
recognizing me not just as sportswoman
or Sports of the year but just Sports
person of the year number nine
let her compete with the men then yo she
got beat by like the 250th dude
it just is what it look I'm a female
athlete okay I played volleyball I
played basketball I ran track in college
I I am an athlete and it's not fun I
don't enjoy that like a mid basketball
guy that played like two years in high
school could probably beat me even
though I played in college but it just
is what it is
like why are we trying to you know I'm
just gonna I'm gonna just play the video
I'm hearty you've done this before
many times when details about the Mad
Max reboot first came to light a lot of
conversation stemmed from the seemingly
female Centric take on a formerly Ultra
Macho franchise this naturally generated
a backlash online from people wanting to
boycott the film because of its alleged
feminist undertones I just wanted to ask
you as you were reading the script did
you ever think why are all these women
in here I thought this was supposed to
be a man's movie during a press
conference in Cannes that focused on
Fury Road the film's male lead Tom Hardy
was asked how he felt about all the
women in the movie his response was
simple but incredibly effective no
not for one minute number eight Kira
Knightley I think
sometimes it is the people who no one
imagines anything of
who do the things that no one can
imagine after being honored with a
Hollywood film award for her portrayal
of Joan Clark in 2014's the imitation
game Keira Knightley was answering the
perfunctory backstage questions one
reporter asked a question that has been
posed to successful women for decades
how she manages to balance her career
and her personal life a question rarely
if ever asked if male actors or
politicians
[Music]
nightly was not gonna let it slide
though and followed up with a question
of her own oh boohoo
boohoo I got asked how I manage it all
stop it stop it
I'm just so tired of women playing the
victim to everything
oh boohoo I'm beautiful oh boohoo I I
I'm getting I don't know what the hell
she I don't understand movies like I'm
not a big movie person but like I'm
winning this award I'm doing good making
a ton of money
and now I'm gonna cry because someone
asked me how I balance my family
look at that's a valid question because
most women want to have families I don't
know if she's got one or what but it
must be hard to man it okay I'm just
gonna number seven Emma Stone I'm Emily
Jean Stone no Emma I love Emma Stone
don't
don't be talking about any woke [ __ ]
Kevin I'm just waiting Russell Garfield
and we are here at our Teen Vogue cover
shoot while the mid-2010 saw team Vogue
shifting towards more Cutting Edge
political coverage back in 2012 they
hadn't exactly hit their stride in terms
of their Progressive slant after
starring together in The Amazing
Spider-Man Emma Stone and Andrew
Garfield were interviewed for the
magazine Emma was asked about her hair
color at one point and in response began
to question why she frequently
experienced these sort of superficial
questions when Andrew interjected okay
I'll tell you why because Emma Stone is
one of the only celebrities that could
pull off every hair color
she's been blonde she's been red she's
been black hair brunette I have never
seen a girl that pulls off different
hair colors like Emma Stone
so you should take that as a compliment
because I don't think I could pull off
another hair color that why she said
quote you get asked interesting poignant
questions because you are a boy and shut
the whole thing down so because he
worked with uh I forget his name Andrew
Garfield or something right yeah
something like that yeah and how did
y'all get along did you get along okay
he's all right yeah it's fine yeah
number six Lauren Conrad make it you I
think that your home should reflect who
you are and your interests and you
should be surrounded by things that you
like and it should be very much your own
aesthetic Lauren Conrad managed to turn
a string of reality TV shows into a
full-fledged career as a lifestyle Guru
she's designed her own fashion line and
published a series of novels that's why
her response to a question posed on a
radio show was so delightfully perfect a
listener asked what her favorite
position was and after a moment of
contemplation she answered CEO favorite
position
hmm
CEO it even took the radio hosts a
minute to catch on to what she just said
CEO
number five oh
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible